we can speak to Alex Rossi who's caught
up in what you see there on the tarmac
at Brussels Airport passengers being
evacuated Alex just give us a summary of
what has happened so far this morning I
was just speaking to an American couple
they progress through check-in pretty
much where we as we had done this
morning we were in duty-free they were
in the sunglass shop they heard the
explosions is well like a state they
felt the building shake it happened what
about an hour ago Babs less than an hour
ago people now have been moved out the
building is being evacuated we've been
moved onto the tarmac coaches have been
laid on here we think they were being
taken to a crisis center it's very
interesting speaking to the American
couple both of them have lived abroad in
East Africa the man Andrew Brandt had
worked in the security forces American
security forces and he said when it
happened there was no doubt in his mind
all his wife's mind that what they had
just heard was a bomb blast it could
have been nothing else they knew at that
point that the airport was under a
terrorist attack